ce soit les missions au risque de vous
plaît aura pour sujet la sexualité
modèle d'essai nous délibérément
pornographiques vous y seront présentés
les années 60 la télé s'amuse d'un petit
rectangle blanc en bas à droite de
l'écran qui signale les contenus
réservés à un public averti
[Musique]
cette signalétique l'ancêtre de nos
moins 10 - 12 et -16 d'aujourd'hui est
apparue il ya 60 ans un avertissement
créée après la diffusion d'un téléfilm
le 29 janvier 1961 sur la seule et
unique chaîne de télévision de l'époque
cette fiction l'exécution a mis le feu
aux poudres
qui sait ce qui n'est gagné
les téléspectateurs indignés écrivent à
la chaîne et au magazine de programmes
télé des flots de protestation qui vont
forcer la chaîne a apposé ce petit signe
sur des programmes multi gieux qui était
carrée avant de devenir rectangle
l'instigateur c'est lui philippe
ragueneau sous directeur des programmes
en 1965 il s'explique il est nécessaire
ce carré blanc car la télévision pénètre
dans les familles sans frapper à la
porte elle s'impose on peut interdire
l'entrée d'une salle de cinéma aux
enfants ne peut pas interdire chez soi
l'ambré des ondes hertziennes
un propos appuyés dans cette même
émission par une psychologue au regard
de mère supérieure le carré blanc et
pour tous les parents une initiative
extrêmement heureuse grâce au carré
blanc ils connaissent le moment où ils
peuvent dire à leurs enfants de quitter
la pièce
mais l' usage de cette petite bande
blanche classe parfois dubitatif
un rectangle blanc sur des pièces de
théâtre comme celle ci le sexe faible
d'edouard bourdet qui parle d'infidélité
conjugale
est ce bien nécessaire ou un rectangle
blanc sur déshabillez-moi de juliette
gréco et ce à cause des paroles excès de
zèle de la télé qui se fait garante de
la moralité
à tel point qu'en 67 le patron des deux
chaînes publiques s'interroge lui même
il est évident que moi aussi il m'est
arrivé d'avoir certaines heures je me
suis demandé pourquoi on mettait le
carré blanc en 1979 le rectangle blanc
disparaît des écrans pour une raison
peut-être pas si surprenante que ça il
est apparu que souvent le carré blanc
était une incitation au contraire à
regarder l'émission dé la part de
sourire de ceux à qui sa démission
devait d'être interdite
il faudra attendre 1996 pour voir le
retour d'une signalétique jeunesse avec
une mise à jour plus clair en 2002 cette
signalétique que l'on connaît bien
maintenant
[Musique]